well that sounds great but how will we
go about building this interactive
prototype we'll need a tool to build it
what we're looking for has three key
aspects first there's interactivity we
only want tools that allow us to build a
clickable prototype all the better if
that prototype can be interacted with on
the target device this is the
fundamental part of medium fidelity
prototype mix so it's non-negotiable we
also want something that is fast we are
busy entrepreneurs and we don't have
time to waste on learning a complex tool
for this task or on building a prototype
in a time-consuming way this is
fundamental to all prototyping remember
we always want the fastest version that
will meet our requirements and get us
the info we need finally we'll want to
be able to get that info from the right
people sometimes the right people for
the job are far away which means that
we'll want a tool that makes it just as
easy to get feedback from some one
halfway across the globe as some one
halfway down the block